Welcome to episode 10 of The Last Cyberneticist.
This episode is called Multenions, A Structured Algebra.
Last episode, we spent quite a bit of time with the 4-bit wonder, so that we could explore
what is required to make substantive claims about machine intelligence, contrast it to
the overblown hype of today's artificial intelligence.
A summary would read, a light at the edge of a circuit is not automatically a fact.
Before it can count as evidence, we have to know which wood was present, which memory
location was selected, which control state the machine occupied, which path carried the
signal, and what operation was actually permitted.
That discipline gave us a finite physical arrangement whose configurations can be treated
as a state system.
The board has a bounded repertoire of conditions, a word can be present or absent on a path,
a memory location can be selected, a read can be valid, a write can be valid, a comparator
can report lower, equal, or higher, the possible situations are not infinite and neither are
the transitions between them, they can be traced.
With that behind us, today I want to pursue a more ambitious question and a bit more dangerous
perhaps.
What if we did not treat that trace merely as a description that we draw after a machine
has been built, let's build a lot of time time up for it, but wonder, a lot of details
about what the consistency of the build is, so what if the state's relations, transformations
and the permitted compositions were themselves the critical material of a program.
If you reflect back to episode 4, we talked about architecture as process, and that was
primarily an evidence-based pursuit, so in the collective context, thereby, the question
we will ask is what mathematical theories are relevant to manifest machine intelligence?
That's the direction I want to introduce Multenions, a structured algebra, what is this stuff?
Multenions is not a name that I invented for this series, it comes from Alexander McAulay,
whose 1908 paper was called "Algebra after Hamilton, or Multenions".
So McAulay worked in the long aftermath of Hamilton's quaternions.
He published Octonions, a development of Clifford's biquaternions in 1898, and he returned
to Multenions in a sequence of papers on differential invariants in the 1920s, the last one being
published in 1921.
So let's pay a little care on the historical line, so it's easy to say okay, we got quaternions
from Hamilton, right, and then we got there's quite being four, right, we got octonions
no, there's two, eight, octo, and the Multenions, which is a multiple of generalization of the
concept, where quaternions are, where any goes for in the Multenions system.
So even though each word looks like a simple ladder of ever larger numbers, it does not,
it's not that way.
So McAulay's octonions were the name for the development of Clifford's biquaternions
specifically, they are not the algebra that is typically called octonions, which is based
on Cayley.
So Multenions is McAulay's later attempt to systemize an algebraic method after Hamilton.
I'm not making a claim on research findings to say it's selling a theory on a thing, I'm
just dropping an example on you here, because this is the stuff that it has to be.
So let's begin this way, I'm not going to make a claim that every finite state controller
is already on McAulay's calculus, it's more of a modest task to see whether the instance
of the name kinds of objects, lawful operations, and explicit compositions can be brought into
contact with programs and machines that we can inspect.
That follows what I've been talking about here and now we're going to bring in some math
stuff.
So the historical correspondence is important because we need to know where stuff comes from.
And you notice in that sentence they use word calculus, so we had an algebra and a calculus
and that's usually split up between okay that's actually something called differential calculus.
So without going into a lot of great detail on this, because it's pretty exhaustive, the
calculus in quaternions was composed in the late 19th century by Peter Tait and Charles
Jasper Joly, and that calculus is substantially or characterless can be different than the
calculus that we talk about Newton and Leibniz.
So we'll go into that in a different way, a different episode, not right now, but let's
reflect that algebra, when you think about the word algebra you think okay it's just
a blackboard full of symbols, a lot of things going on, an algebra, I mean obviously the
word is from the Arabic, we came out in that form in the 7th century AD, but algebra is
far far far far far older, we can trace it back to about 5,500 years ago, that's the
earliest record like a document that we have that shows that that's being used to do you
know useful things in the physical world.
So it's something that's been on for a long time we've known about it and it's something
that we have to be aware of when we're doing machine intelligence because we have a lot
of expectations that are already set up by us by the marketing of artificial intelligence,
but more on the lines of that we have traceability and we have already set out the things that
we want to do, machines that we can inspect, and so we already have a very rigorously
defined set of conditions, and we can now explore algebra in a way that we don't have
to put restrictions on it, we can be more free in this way, and find out, okay, let's
see how algebra can be useful to help us determine what we want to accomplish, we want to structure,
we want to talk to the architecture, we want to structure, and the algebra will tell us
what the kinds of things we're dealing with and what can be done with them, and what follows
when those operations are combined, so it doesn't merely name objects, it makes your relations
and transformations, answerable to rules, so that matters here because a finite state
program should be more than just a list of instructions hidden in a processor, look at
that table just to execute those things, no, it should be pursued as an exercise in explicit
algebraic objects, so a state is an object, a permitted transformation is an object, and
in relation between states is an object, composition is an object, a condition that blocks or allows
a transition is an object, and a trace of what happened is an object of inquiry as well,
but don't get the word object confused with the class objects in object-oriented programming,
these are different things, we're talking object in a more primitive way, so it's just
like a, I think it was a container, so let's not go too far with this, let's not say that
every flowchart is an algebra, or that attaching a mathematical language to a program makes
it so profound, it is the demand enough for a structure that we can say what a program
is made of, what it may or may not do next, and what particular result follows, so this
demand is becoming more important as we go, because we live among systems that produce
striking results, without always taking the route, to find out how the results are easier
to recover, so let's look at the stuff we got up, we got in front of this here, so a lot
of the contemporary AI is built upon linear algebra, and trained through gradient-based
optimizations, so large collections of examples become parameters, and those parameters are
adjusted until a system becomes better at a specified task, so tuning, so the resulting
system may classify, generate, predict or control, in ways that are genuinely useful,
so we're not saying anything bad or dismissing it, so a gradient-trained system is very powerful,
precisely because it finds regularities that no person can write that one at a time, it
can use a scale of examples and a density of calculations that a small explicit program
can't match it, but let's be very careful again to say that power and legibility are
completely different virtues, so from the outside, a large trained system can feel like
a search through a vast territory of possible answers, it's not literally the traveling
salesman calculation, it shouldn't really describe this one, but the comparison is quite
normal, because it looks that way from the outside, so but the resemblance is experimental,
not experiential, more or less, a procedure that moves through an enormous space, according
to a rule of improvements and eventually arrives at a result, it may work without offering
a compact account of why this particular internal route was taken, so at its most superficial,
the relation to data can resemble, that's more like train spotting, so you're sitting
at a distance and you're watching a train pass you with freight cars and you're pointing
out okay, there's this, but the data has a pants bias, immense collections of particulars
are gathered, matched and made statistically useful, what's difficult is not that the system
has no structure, it's a great deal of structure, but the difficulty is much that the operate
of structure is distributed across learned parameters, rather than presented as a small
public vocabulary of objects and operations, we've already talked about how everything
is hype and a bunch of BS, but why is it BS?
This is what we're getting at now, this is what, but this is what comes rather interesting,
so the contrast is not to say, it's not intelligence against stupidity or new technology against
old technology, it's not that simplistic, not us and them, it's between two different
two different and very, very distinct ways of pursuing a machine, so one way asks whether
a system can find a useful answer from examples, that's what I'm doing here, the other asks
whether the terms of its conduct can be made explicit enough to construct, inspect, change
and prove, so Multenions belongs to the second, the latter one, so by calling Multenions
a structured algebra, it means that its intended structure is not an afterthought, it's a direct
thing that we want to leverage, so elements are not merely numbers placed in a container
and sent through a calculation, they stand in specified, well-defined relations to each
other, the transformations are not merely whatever instructions happen to be convenient, they
are part of what the system is, the composition is not merely putting one operation after another,
it is where the system declares how one lawful change can become the condition for the next,
so the important way is structured, structure is what prevents a collection of marks from
becoming an invitation to say anything we like, so in terms of like physical circuits,
electronic circuits, it is distinction between an address line and a data line, between selective
membership and a deselected one, between a recondition and right condition, in an algebraic
program, it is distinction between the kinds of object and the operations that may join
them, so we can begin this way before demanding any notation, before any we start writing anything
at all, this is how we would set this up as, so imagine a small controller for a door,
as four states, closed, open, opening and closing, so it receives a few named events,
a request to enter, a fully open sensor, a fully closed sensor and an obstruction signal,
the controller has a few named transformations, our request applied to, our request applied
to closed, begins opening, a fully open sensor applied to an opening produces open, a timeout
applied to open begins closing and obstruction applied to closing returns the system to opening,
so that is a finite state program that is described, its value is not that it's a complex thing,
it's a value that it's a possible conduct that can lay out, without pretending the door
it has a hidden personality, there's no man behind the curtain, we can ask whether the
obstruction transition is present, we can ask whether the closed door can become open, without
passing through an opening, we can ask whether this, there is a state in which no event is
handled, we can test a trace, closed, request, opening, fully open, open, timeout, closing,
obstruction, opening, so what's next, we make the demand stronger, do not leave those names
as labels in the diagram, so treat state, event, transformation and composition as explicit
objects in the program's account of itself, a transition is not merely a sentence and
a manual, it is an entity that can be inspected for its source, its condition, its destination
and consequence, a composition is not merely an accident of control flow, it is a declared
way in which one transformation becomes available after another, so that's the kind of exercise
that this episode 10 is concerned with, the pursuit of finite state programs becomes the
pursuit of explicit algebraic objects, so there is a useful difference between an object
and a value, number four is a value, but the four that names this memory address, the four
that is the current candidate and the four that is the target are not interchangeable
objects, even when they share the same representation, the same numeric representation, typically
in a binary, but the roles determine what operations are appropriate, so we learn that
when the same four wires can be harmless data in one condition, they can also be a misleading
apparent result in another, the same four wires, and an explicit algebraic program must
preserve that distinction, it should not collapse every meaningful difference into an anonymous
number or bare memory location or just a line of code whose role is remembered by the guy
who wrote it, and maybe didn't document, so no one knows anything is going on, but it
should make room to ask, what is the object, where did it come from, which relation does
it stand in, what can act upon it, and what has to be true before the action is valid,
so that does not mean that every program has to carry a long philosophical explanation
of itself, it just means that the structure needs to understand its conduct and not treated
as disposable commentary, just put those notes on the document, no one is going to read it
and it actually belongs to the construction, so a good label can be "help", a type can
help, you know, like an object during a program, a table can help, a physical separation of
paths can help, but none by itself is enough, the question is whether a program's stated
objects and operations genuinely constrain one another, so reflect back on the door controller
example, a simple list of commands might say, okay, if the obstruction sensor is active,
command the motor to open, that can work, right, but then there's several questions of that
remain hidden, is the door currently closing, does the obstruction matter while it's already
open, does the command cancel appending closed or merely add another instruction to the queue,
what happens if the fully open sensor never arrives, so these are like we just say, okay,
those are edge cases, we add them after the real program, but they're part of the program's
possible conduct, now in our structured approach that we're proposing here, those questions
are put to the forefront, so the structure itself asks whether the obstruction is an
event valid in every state or in only certain states, it asks whether opening is a state,
an operation or both a different level of description, it asks whether a timeout composes
with an obstruction and what order, it asks what the trace provides, that that controller
returned to a safe state, the result may still be implemented with the ordinary electronics
or ordinary code, right, but what changes the discipline is by which its behavior is
specified and checked, so this is why the contrast with opaque systems should not be
heard in an argument against calculation, it's too easily people will slide into this kind
of us and M0 sum, this is not about that, explicit structures also calculate, they can
be large, fast and demanding, the difference is that their decisive transformations are
intended to remain presentable as operations are named kinds of objects, so a listener,
a builder or a later repairer can follow a transition without having to reconstruct
an entire history of training data and parameter adjustment and that's the extreme savings
of this idea, of course there's always trade-offs, right, an explicit finite state structure
that can become unwieldy when the world describes as too many relevant conditions, think about
how a robot constructs its environment, a learned system may handle variation and hand
specified controller can anticipate these things, but a learned system can also conceal
a distinction that safety maintenance or accountability requires us to keep it visible, there you
know, accountability, that seems to be always missing, but the right question is not which
method wins everywhere, it is where the explicit structure has a condition to trust, so the
phrase exercise, that matters, that means something, it doesn't mean the program is
a toy, it means we learn the structure by performing it, we identify an object, we state
an operation, we ask what composition is allowed, we test the consequence, we find an exception,
we revise the account, our finite state program becomes less like a spell, there's some spooky
magic that a computer does, it just happens to magically do that, oh it's obeying, but
it looks more like a work proof of possible conduct, so keep beating this 4-bit wonder
but it remains useful because it keeps the discussion honest, manual comparison does not
yet supply a controller, and it doesn't hold a target independently, we decided next action
revise a candidate or even verify it a completed cycle, but it exposes several objects we would
need, a remembered word, a target word, a relation between them, a valid recondition, a valid
recondition and visible trace, so let's say we wanted to make one small addition, a controller
could inspect the comparator, if the remembered word were lower than the target, it could transform
the candidate upper by one, contrarily if it were higher, it could transform the candidate
downward by one, if it were equal it would stop, the states of the imagined controller
we're talking about here, it might be capture target, read candidate, compare, step upward,
step downward, write candidate, verify and halt, so we're not going to do any particular
arithmetic here on this one, we're just saying that each item can be named and distinguished
by the method that I'm describing here, so the target is not the candidate, the comparison
is not a decision, the decision is not a right, the right is not a verification, the completion
condition is not a decorative light, it prevents the process from continuing after the state
of objective has been reached one more time, it prevents the process of continuing after
the state objective has been reached, so in a structured algebra, the distinctions are
not really good habits for a careful engineer, they are candidates for the very objects and
operations to which the program is expressed, so that's the bridge from a finite state diagram
to a finite state program with intelligible form, let me get into the intelligence now,
so this is an interesting experiment on my own, I'm going to see if I can do a small
code fragment here in speech, see how it goes, so there's a small fragment, I'm going to
set it as a program rather than a diagram, so let candidate and target the distinct objects,
and then we'll create a method, compare candidate target, that yields one relation, don't lower
equal or higher, only lower permits step up, method candidate, only higher permits step
down candidate, and only the result of one of those steps permits right to the candidate
store, right target is not an alternative spelling of the same operation, it is forbidden by
the stated rules, so normally write, follow directly from compare, the relation is evidence,
not yet it provides value, so the short sequence is such, compare, lower, step up, write, verify,
and that would tell that process, that sequence would tell another builder both what may happen
and what not must not be skipped, so at this point after that let's, it's fair to ask what
makes Multenions unique about algebras, let me kind of close up with this, so the answer
is not just it's a remarkable name, it's not unique as we say it so, then we want to think
about this in terms of a thesis, right, so let's kind of pivot here a little bit, I think
I'll do this here, so if uniqueness, if we're saying something that's unique, it must be
earned by a particular kind of objects, operations, constraints, and compositions, right, so let's
kind of frame it in those ways, so instead of settling the thesis by pretending to settle
it by assertion, which is typical, Multenions proposes that there is a distinctive structured
account of programmatic conduct available here, now I'll need to explain more what that means
in the next episodes that are coming up after this, so that way the, this proposal can get
a boom, a sharp reform, but we have to begin by stating what the element, what the element
your objects are, we need to show what operations are permitted and forbidden, so we need to
demonstrate a composition that would be, that would be obscure if left as an ordinary control
flow, and we need to build or simulate a finite example whose behavior can be checked, so
that's just something to explain that what we have to get into, to know that we're talking
about the right thing, so there's an important, there's an important practical consequence,
so when a program is arranged as an explicit algebraic object, failure has an address, if
a controller takes an impossible transition, we can ask whether the state object was wrong,
whether the event was misidentified, whether a condition was omitted, whether an invalid
composition was allowed, if the program reached the right result for the wrong reasons, we
can compare the trace for the declared structure, if a new feature is proposed, we can ask which
object it adds and which existing compositions it changes, so not saying that this whole
explicit system will be easy, some of the hardest systems in engineering are difficult
because precisely because their structures are made visible and must be kept consistent,
but in this case, the difficulty can be located, the difficulties that are located are different
in other ways, because the difficulty arrives as an unexplained output, so by those rather,
I think it's rather simple ways of explaining it, it changes, this changes what it means
to learn programming, so a beginner, so I'm going to just start, now it is often handed
a language, a syntax and an assignment, make this computer do something, so that can teach
useful skills, but apparently AI is going to be doing it for everybody, so why bother
learning it, but that's not exactly the wrong way to think about it, we're not going to
leave with the fact that a program is a string of commands whose internal form is accepted
on trust, though this trust is that you don't even need to know the stuff that AI is going
to do everything, just trust and trust, build up those layers of trust and just, you know,
take a word for it, no, I don't think so, the finite state approach begins somewhere a
little more concrete, let's say, there would be too much on it here, so what states can
the system occupy with distinctions matter here, what event changes with state, what transformations
are allowed, and how do we know which result is valid, and what trace would another person
need in order to repeat the claims, now, there you go, that would be science, so those are
algebraic questions before the questions of a particular programming language, and those
are also cybernetic questions, by the way, cybernetics asks about control communication
and feedback in organized systems, but control without a visible account of the state can
become mysticism, teleology, feedback without an explicit relation can become slogan, the
value of a structured algebra is that it presses the vocabulary down toward the machine, it
asks whether the relation is held, what transformation occurs, what condition enables it, and what
consequence follows, so the goal here is not to make every machine small, large systems
will still exist and some will remain trained, statistically distributed and difficult to
compress into a handful of objects, so the goal is to reserve another lineage of technical
work, systems that are designed to reveal the terms of operation, so in closing the lineage
that I'm talking about here needs both a formal account and a physical home, a finite state
program cannot remain a philosophical diagram, its object must eventually be represented
somewhere, the table, memory, and register in a program image, run a wire on a sequence
of observed actions, its operations must be timing, power failure, and the ordinary resistance
of material systems, so for now, Multenions gives us a direction to travel, we will pursue
finite state programs as explicit algebraic objects, we will ask whether the operations
can be structured, so the machine's conduct remains visible, not only after produced result
but while it's being built to test the repaired and changed, so in the next episode we will
start to look at whether these explicit objects can survive contact with a real machine, but
in order to detail that, we will need to take a small segue into discussing algorithms, because
if you, we talk about composition and the algebra is law for compositions, what processes
but algorithms are we going to execute that makes this compatible, makes it work in a
way that we are expecting it to, and that's for next time, thank you for listening.